there's a woman that accuses a man of
cheating and the other woman owns up to
lying let's play the clip what is like
respectful in a relationship trusting
the person and not paying somebody to
see if they would cheat but it happened
not true you went on a date with this
girl it wasn't a date she literally told
me that you took her out to eat oh yeah
and you guys hooked up you can't sit
here and deny that I am denying cuz it's
not true it okay sure she's a client and
after we were working out we got food
which was across the street where that's
not what she told me that's what I'm
telling she told me you guys had sex
telling you we didn't so are you saying
she's lying I'm saying she's lying let's
find out from her okay Paula can you
tell him what you told me so I pretty
much told her that he took me to this
really fancy restaurant and afterwards
we went back to my place and hooked up
and that he came on to you in the car
and you guys are kissing yes yeah see
why would you sit here and lie I lied
because so you weren't telling the truth
I didn't think that she deserved you so
I lied